Bienvenidos a esta nueva edición del
programa enlace econosur desde la ciudad
de Río de Janeiro en el que hablaremos
de las elecciones presidenciales de
Brasil que culminaron el 30 de octubre
con la victoria de Luis Ignacio Luna da
Silva con más de 60 millones de
sufragios el fundador del partido de los
trabajadores es el presidente más votado
de la historia de Brasil porque este año
el número de electores creció un 6%, en
realidad su Victoria fue muy ajustada
con el 50,9% de los votos
Lula da Silva también es el único
presidente de Brasil que ejercerá un
tercer mandato recordamos que el ya
gobernó entre el 2003 y 2011 en este
programa analizaremos todos los retos
que aguardan el nuevo presidente de
Brasil durante la fase de transición y
en su mandato que empieza el 1 de enero
de 2023
estamos en la Plaza de la cinelandia el
centro de la vida política de Río de
Janeiro y también un reducto de la
izquierda aquí el 30 de octubre millares
de Seguidores de Luna celebraron su
triunfo y el fin de la Era bolsonaro una
verdadera marea roja invadió este lugar
un clima de alegría Vimos a muchas
personas que lloraban conmocionadas y
bailaban muchos se abrazaban como si se
conocieran la emoción estaba flor de
piel esto es los que nos dijeron algunos
partidarios de
lulado hoy estoy aliviado porque parece
que La pesadilla está acabando vamos a
recomenzar ahora Este es un nuevo Brasil
vamos a volver a ser grandes a hacer lo
que éramos va a acotarse quien esencial
esta Victoria Aunque por un pequeño
margen fue una victoria muy importante
para la democracia aquí en Brasil
tuvimos 21 años de una dictadura civil
militar muy violenta bolsonaron
representa el pensamiento de esta
dictadura la democracia venció a la
dictadura
A 400 kilómetros de esta plaza en la
emblemática avenida paulista en San
Pablo decenas de millares de Seguidores
de Lula acompañaron el convoy del recién
elegido presidente de Brasil Lula
discurso al lado de yamcha su esposa y
de sus aliados hizo un discurso
conciliador y prometió gobernar para
todos los brasileños
a partir y primero de febrero de 2023 a
partir del primero de enero de 2023
gobernaré para 215 millones de
brasileños no solo para los que votaron
por mí no existen dos brasiles somos un
solo país un solo pueblo una gran nación
[Aplausos]
en la otra punta de la ciudad muchos
seguidores de Jairo bolsonaro se
congregaron delante de su casa en un
barrio llamando barra de tijuca durante
todo el escrutinio rezaron por la
victoria de su líder con mucho fervor
dos problemas de Jesucristo Amén Cuando
quedó claro que bolsonara había sido
Derrotado con Dios el desespero Vimos a
muchos seguidores del presidente
abatidos e inconformados
el otro El ladrón ganó un antiguo preso
como puede ganar las elecciones un
antiguo preso si es un ladrón pero el
pueblo ya está saturado estamos hartos
el pueblo no lo aceptará
es el único presidente de Brasil que no
consiguió la reelección también es el
único mandatario que no se pronunció
tras conocer los resultados lo hizo dos
días después en un pronunciamiento
telegráfico en el que no felicitó a su
rival
En cuántos precios
como presidente de la república y
ciudadano seguiré cumpliendo todos mis
mandamientos de nuestra constitución
de millones de brasileños que como yo
defiende la libertad económica la
libertad religiosa la libertad de
opinión la honestidad y los colores
verde y amarillo de nuestra bandera
en los sondeos alcanzó el 54% de rechazo
de la población en cambio luna ostentaba
el 87% de popularidad cuando dejó el
poder por dos razones el crecimiento
económico que transformó Brasil en la
sexta mayor Economía del mundo y el
amplio paquete de medidas sociales que
estimularon la inclusión de las camadas
más Humildes ahora Lola tiene varios
retos por delante primero hacer una
transición pacífica y eficiente sin
conocer el real estado de las cuentas
públicas es imposible trazar una
política económica eficiente y realista
de Cara a los próximos cuatro años
además en ula tendrá que esforzarse
mucho para conseguir la gobernabilidad
con un parlamento dominado por partidos
de derecha para de este tema hemos
combinado a la politóloga Carolina
Almera de Paola de la universidad
Estatal de Río de Janeiro durante su
primer mandato Lula estuvo en el centro
de un escándalo llamado mensalao que
consistía en comprar el voto de algunos
congresistas para conseguir una mayoría
que puede hacer sin tener que recurrir a
este tipo de mecanismos lo que notamos
ahora con el resultado de la Selección
legislativas en la primera vuelta es que
hay una fragmentación menor que en el
período anterior de otros gobiernos de
Lula entonces a pesar de tener todavía
muchos partidos percibimos que fue
positivo en el sentido de reducir la
fragmentación Lula siendo un hábil
negociador con el congreso como él ya
fue en 2006 va a precisar ampliar el
abanico de partidos que le ayudaron a
salir elegido ahora
uniforme para Luna la prioridad ahora es
combatir el hambre que afecta más de 33
millones de brasileños además aumentar
el salario mínimo y crear un ministerio
para los pueblos indígenas sus electores
también esperan que recupere el
Ministerio de cultura que fue extinguido
por evolucionar en una especie de
Cruzada electoral que recupera el
Ministerio de Educación ocupado en los
últimos cuatro años por conservadores e
incluso por pastores y que reflote la
economía muy afectada por la inflación y
la pandemia del coronavirus hasta aquí
nuestro enlace cono Sur desde la ciudad
de Río de Janeiro sobre las elecciones
presidenciales de Brasil yo soy Valeria
saconi y la cámara está mi colega Fanny
lotek Hasta pronto